hello everyone
i'm followed by diabetes from nigeria
um i currently work as a researcher
as university college hospital important
here in nigeria and i'm so glad to be
here today to present
the findings of my current um study with
you all um titled drug i get exploration
in hyper virulence klebsiella and many
strains
and i i hope to be an enlightening
session so what are these strains what
are they they are an imagine sub type of
clever pneumonia
and they are defined by presence of
many different biomarkers
such as um plasmid
plasmids that carry
genes responsible for aerobactine birth
influences genes that carry the rnp
and rnp2
capsule microregulators
in this
picture here we can see
a mocoid string this string is um
above five millimeter in length
this is one of the initial
identification means of this particular
string
however this is not a definitive like i
said
there are many different biomarkers
that are used to identify to have a
definitive elevation of these particular
strains
wherever they are they are found
so these strains are they're known to
cause
severe diseases
um like liver abscesses meningitis
bone um severe inflammatory and invasive
infections such as
sepsis
now one of the um
dangerous
feature of this particular um strain is
the rapid evolution
and development of
confluence of hyperviolence
drug resistance and esp resistance
amongst millennial resistance um
feature
so
this particular
picture here is a
plasmid carrying boots hyperviolence um
biomarkers
like the rnp and rmp2 and the others
um painted in blue as well as
a better lifetime resistance gene
this is one of the features of this
particular strain are boring um
resistance genes
as well as virulence biomarker um
on a single plasmid and this has caused
the failure of available attributes to
effectively treat them
so and currently they see wide global
dissemination of this particular strain
although they are
the reports have been coming in mainly
from china
there have been other reports in many
other countries like the us
in germany the uk
saudi arabia in india and singapore
in italy and even here in africa
because currently in my laboratory
there's a particular strain in which um
the ipam viscose um
string
was identified
current um study is is going on
apparently on the particular strength to
ascertain
if it is a violent strain or not
so as a result of this
um field of antibiotics and the rapid
semitone and evolution of the particular
stream
this
study is
is aimed at
um exploring the hypothetical proteins
of four different um
hyperbarics considered immunostrains
in order to identify number drug targets
and also identify
vaccine candidates which will be
effective in tackling these menace so
here is um
the overall workflow
of this project either that is not yet
conclusive but this is how the project
has been going so far
the sequence were retrieved retrieved
from uniprot
and were put through during analysis to
identify to attain the essentiality
they are um functions the drug ability
and those of other
characteristics
so
many of the analyses were done using
biophromatic resources like the
protein blast interpro for function
function prediction the p farm
the string analysis
drug bank and also furthers and as you
can see um on this screen with the
parameters with which i conducted each
analysis
analysis i found out that the
proteome retrieved from uniprot
contained a total of
557 protein sequences
of which foreign one of them were
hypothetical proteins
of this absolute proteins 20 of them
were returned as essential anonymous to
any human
um
protein
this diagram here shows us the breakdown
and the
result of the screening up until a
doctor get was identified
the one um protein was found to interact
with 15 um
human proteins 15 different sigma
proteins and this um
is quite important if the particular
protein
interacts with so many human proteins it
shows how much
of um
essentiality or importance
it's old for the particular pathogen
and also this particular protein showed
a metabolic pathway activity
particularly the carbohydrate metabolic
metabolism so this particular protein
was found to be and to interact with
um different drugs in the drug bank
database
so this particular drug um protein is
not um a negative level however
it can be together for the analysis
because
there is currently no no drug
used
against particular pathogens less
strains
so i believe this particular protein
can be used to um
develop
um
drugs
having a b3 activities that kind of
build this particular protein
considering it's numerous um
functions and it's an important activity
for the protein considering the
interaction with too many different
human proteins and its
activity
in metabolic pathways in human
so one daughter was identified from the
particular strain and this result shows
the potential of the method used in this
particular experiment and identifying
targets from remaining strains
which are currently being analyzed
so i believe completing this particular
study
we provide effective and reliable drug
targets or vaccine candidates against
the rising menace
it has been used um effectively
particularly in developing the bacterial
vaccine
for guppy medical cocos
so
it has also been used in
bacterial substances cigala flectionary
proteins and their interactions
with
drugs
known drugs in the drug bank database
so i believe this particular project um
we provide
um
information and data which will help in
identifying
the red dot target that can be to tackle
this menace
so much